Hi there my name’s John Green; this is Crash Course
World History and today we’re going to talk about Jesus.
So this is a Roman coin from around the time
Jesus was born in the Roman Empire, and it
calls Augustus, the emperor, the son of God.
So let’s just state at the outset that in
4 BCE, being the son of God, or at least being
the son of a god was not such an unusual thing.
But a poor Jew being the son of God — that
was news.
[Theme Music]
Any understanding of Christianity has to start
with Judaism, because Jesus was born a Jew,
and he grew up in the Jewish tradition. He
was one of many teachers spreading his ideas
in the Roman province of Judea at the time,
and he was part of a messianic tradition that
helps us understand why he was thought of
not only teacher but something much, much more.
Let’s go straight to the Thought Bubble
today.
The people who would become the Jews, were
just one of many tribal peoples eking out
an existence in that not-very fertile crescent
world of Mesopotamia after the agricultural revolution.
The Hebrews initially worshiped many gods,
making sacrifices to them in order to bring
good weather and good fortune. But they eventually
developed a religion centered around an idea
that would become key to the other great western
religions.
This was monotheism, the idea that there is
only one true god (or at least that if there
are other gods around, they are total lameoids).
The Hebrews developed a second concept that
is key to their religion as well: the idea
of the covenant, a deal with God.
The main man in this, the big macher was Abraham.
Not to make this too much of a scripture lesson,
but it’s kind of hard to understand the
Jews without understanding Abraham, or Abram
as he was known before he had his big conversation
with God. Recorded in Genesis 17: "When Abram
was ninety years and nine, the LORD appeared
to Abram, and said unto him, 'I am the Almighty
God; walk before me, and be thou perfect.'
" And I’m a make a covenant with you and
a bunch of cool things will happen like you’re
gonna have kids and your descendants will
number the stars and you can have all the
land of Canaan forever, it’s gonna be awesome.
I’m paraphrasing by the way, Thought Bubble.
So God promised that Abram would have kids
with his wife even though the dude was already
like 99, but there was a catch: "This is my
covenant, which ye shall keep, between me
and you and thy seed after thee; every man
child among you shall be circumcised." Keep
it PG-13, Thought Bubble.
Now that is asking a lot from a guy, especially
a 99-year-old geezer like Abram living in
a time before general anesthesia. But those
were the terms of the deal, and in exchange
God had chosen Abraham and his descendants
to be a great nation. From this we get the
expression that the Jews are the Chosen people.
Thanks for keeping it clean, Thought Bubble.
So, some important things about this god:
One, singularity. He — and I’m using the
masculine pronoun because that’s what Hebrew
prayers use — does not want you to put any
gods before Him.
He is also transcendent, having always existed
and he is deeply personal – he chats with
prophets, sends locusts, etc. But he doesn’t
take corporeal form like the Greek and Roman Gods do.
He is also involved in history, like he will
destroy cities, and bring floods, and determine
the outcome of wars, and possibly football
games. Stan, no! FOOTBALL games!
Probably most important to us today, and certainly
most important to Jesus, this god demands
moral righteousness and social justice. So,
this is the god of the Hebrews, Yahweh, and
despite many ups and downs, the Jewish people
have stuck with him for- according to the
Hebrew calendar, at least- over 5700 years.
And He has stuck by them too, despite the
Jews being, on occasion, something of a disappointment
to him. Which leads to various miseries, and
also to a tradition of prophets who speak
for God and warn the people to get back on
the right path lest there be more miseries.
Which brings us back to our friends, the Romans.
By the time that Jesus was born, the land
of the Israelites had been absorbed into the
Roman Empire as the province of Judea. At
the time of Jesus’s birth, Judea was under
the control of Herod the Great, best known
for building the massive temple in Jerusalem,
that the Romans would later destroy.
And by the time Jesus died, an expanded Judea
was under the rule of Herod Antipater. Also,
unhelpfully, known as Herod. Both Herods ultimately
took their orders from the Romans, and they
both show up on the list of rulers who are
oppressive to the Jews, partly because there’s
never that much religious freedom in an empire.
Unless you are, wait for it... The Mongols
[Mongoltage]
or the Persians. Also, they were Hellenizers,
bringing in Greek theater and architecture,
and rationalism. And in response to those
Hellenistic influences, there were a lot of
preachers trying to get the Jews to return
to the traditions and the godly ways of the
past, including the Sadducees, and the Pharisees,
and the Essenes, and the Zealots.
And one of those preachers, who didn’t fit
comfortably into any of these four groups,
was Jesus of Nazareth. Jesus was a preacher
who spread his message of peace, love and,
above all, justice, across Judea over the
course of his actually average-length life for his time.
He was remarkably charismatic, attracting
a small but incredibly loyal group of followers,
and he was said to perform miracles — although
it’s worth noting that miracles weren’t
terribly uncommon at the time.
Jesus’s message was particularly resonant
to the poor and downtrodden and pretty radical
in its anti-authoritarian stance. He said
it was easier for a camel to get through the
eye of a needle than for a rich man to get
to heaven, he said the meek were blessed,
that the last would be first and the first
would be last — all of which was kind of
threatening to the powers that be, who accordingly
had him arrested, tried and then executed
in the normal method of killing rebels at
that time: crucifixion.
Also, just to put this question to bed, the
Romans crucified Jesus, because he was a
threat to their authority. Later traditions saying that the
Jews killed Jesus? Very unfortunate, also, very untrue.
We’re not going to discuss Jesus’s divinity,
because:
1. This isn’t a theology class, and
2. Flame wars on the Internet make me so uncomfortable that
I have to turn to camera 2. Hi there camera
2, I’m here to remind you that
3. Fighting over such things, like fighting
over whether the proverbial cake is a lie,
rarely accomplishes anything, plus
4. What matters to us is the historical fact
that people at the time believed that Jesus
was the Messiah, the Anointed One, the son
of God. And they believed that he would return
some day to redeem the world.
Which leads us to two questions about Christianity:
First, Why did this small group of people
believe this? And second, why and how did
that belief become so widespread?
So why would people believe that Jesus was
the Messiah?
First. The Jews had a long tradition of believing
that a savior who would come to them in a
time of trouble. And Judea under the rule
of Herod and the Romans... definitely a time of trouble.
And many of the prophecies about this savior
point to someone whose life looks a lot like
Jesus's. For instance, Isaiah 53 says the
person will be misunderstood and mistreated,
just like Jesus was: “He was despised, and
rejected by men; a man of sorrows, and acquainted
with grief: and as one from whom men hide
their face he was despised; and we didn't respect him.”
And a lot of the prophecies like Daniel 7:14,
for instance, explained that when the Messiah
comes there will be this awesome, new, everlasting
kingdom. And that had to sound pretty good
to people who’d had their autonomy taken
away from them.
So some religious Jews saw Jesus in those
prophecies and came to believe either during
his life or shortly thereafter, that he was
the messiah. Most of them thought the new
everlasting kingdom was right around the corner,
which is probably why no one bothered to write
down much about the life of Jesus for several
decades, by which time it was clear that we
might have to wait a bit for this brilliant
new everlasting kingdom.
I should note, by the way, that the idea of
a messiah was not unique to the Jews at the
time. Even the Romans got in on the action,
for instance, the Roman poet Virgil wrote
of a boy who: “Shall free the earth from
never-ceasing fear, he shall receive the life
of gods, and see Heroes with gods commingling.”
Sound familiar?
But Virgil was writing about Emperor Augustus
in that poem, not Jesus, which points again
to the similarities between the two. Both
called sons of God. Both sent to free the
earth from never-ceasing fear. But one ruled
the largest empire in the world; and the other
believed that empire, and the world, needed
to change dramatically.
So why did the less wealthy and famous son
of God become by far the more influential?
Well, here are three possible historical reasons:
Reason #1: The Romans continued to make things
bad for the Jews. In fact, things got much
worse for the Jews, especially after they launched
a revolt between 66-73 CE, which did not go well.
By the time the dust settled, the Romans had
destroyed the Temple and expelled the Jews
from Judea, beginning what we now know
as the Jewish Diaspora.
And without a Temple or geographic unity,
the Jews had to solidify what it meant to
be a Jew and what the basic tenants of the
religion were. This forced the followers of
Jesus to make a decision: were they going
to continue to be Jews following stricter
laws set forth by rabbis, or were they going
to be something else.
The decision to open up their religion to
non-Jews, people who weren’t part of the
covenant, is the central reason that Christianity
could become a world religion instead of just
a sect of Judaism. And it probably didn’t
hurt that the main proponent of sticking with
Judaism was James, Jesus’s brother, who
was killed by the Romans.
Reason #2: Is related to Reason #1 and it’s
all about a dude named Saul. No, not that
Saul. Yes, Saul of Tarsus, thank you.
Saul, having received a vision on the road
to Damascus, became Paul and began visiting
and sending letters to Jesus followers throughout
the Mediterranean. And it was Paul who emphatically
declared that Jesus followers did NOT have
to be Jews, that they did not have to be circumcised
or keep to Jewish laws or any of that stuff.
This opened the floodgates for thousands of
people to convert to this new religion. And
the other thing to remember about Paul is
that he was a Roman citizen, which meant that
he could travel freely throughout the Roman
Empire. This allowed him to make his case
to lots of different people and facilitated
the geographic spread of Christianity.
Oh, it’s time for the open letter? Alright.
An open letter, to the fish.
But first, lets see what’s in the secret
compartment today. Oh, Stan. It’s my favorite
album Jesus Christ Superstar, finally available
in my favorite format, the cassette. Did I
color-coordinate my shirt to Jesus Christ
Superstar? Yes.
Dear Ichthys, So check this out: In the first
century when it was still super underground
and hipster to be a Christian, you were a
secret symbol of Christianity, used to kind
of hide from the Romans. Ichthys, the Greek
word for fish, was an acronym and it was a
super clever way to talk about religion without
anyone knowing that you were talking about it.
But you’ll never guess what happened - even
in places where it’s completely fine to
talk about Christianity now and to use, you
know, regular Christian symbols, like the
cross, you have had a huge resurgence thanks
to the plastic automobile decal industry.
I mean seriously, Ichthys, I haven’t seen
a comeback like this since Jesus.
Best wishes, John Green
And lastly, Christianity was born and flourished
an empire with a common language that allowed
for its spread. And crucially, it was also
an Empire in decline.
Like even by the end of the first century
CE, Rome was on its way down. And for the
average person, and even for some elites,
things weren’t as good as they had been,
if fact they were getting worse so fast that you
might have thought the end of the world was coming.
And Roman religion offered no promise of an
afterlife, and a bunch of squabbling whiny
gods - sorry if I offended adherents to Roman
religion, but seriously, they squabble. So
even though early Christians were persecuted
by the Roman Empire and sometimes fed to the
lions and other animals, the religion continued
to grow, albeit slowly.
But then as the Roman decline continued, Emperor
Constantine allowed the worship of Jesus and
then eventually converted to Christianity
himself. And then the religion really took
off. I mean, Rome wasn’t what it used to
be, but everybody still wanted to be like
the Emperor. And soon enough there was a new
son of God on coins.
Thanks for watching. See you next week.
Crash Course is produced and directed by Stan
Muller, our script supervisor is Danica Johnson.
The show is written by my high school history
teacher Raoul Meyer and myself and our graphics
team is Thought Bubble.
As only 62 million of you guessed last week,
the Phrase of the Week was "Chipotle Burrito";
if you want to guess at this week’s Phrase
of the Week or suggest future ones, you can
do so in Comments where you can also ask questions
about today’s video that will be answered,
hopefully, by our team of historians.
Thanks for watching Crash Course, and as we
say in my hometown, Don't Forget To Be Awesome.
Ow... again.